bisher unsere erste grenze und das ist
eine so wichtige und die empfehle ich
wirklich allen nicht gemeinsam in einem
bett schlafen
ok ja das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
liebe leute herzlich kommen zu einem
neuen video ich glaube wir werden heute
ein video sehen was sonst verwirrend
wird aber bevor wir im video anfangen
will ich eine sache vorne weg schicken
mir ist es wichtig zu betonen dass es
prinzipiell nichts schlechtes ist dinge
anders als andere zu machen oder anders
zu machen als leute ist vielleicht
erwarten dass man es macht doch das muss
ich vorneweg sagen die werden heute zwei
leute sehen die dinge sehr anders machen
als alle anderen um ganz genau zu sein
leute ich werde heute auch zwei
christliche youtuber und ihre
einstellungen zu liebe beziehungen und
intimität zwischen zwei menschen
reagieren stabil
[Musik]
ok also wir sind sieger auf dem
bildschirm das video ist von dem account
lee marie und ich glaube die marie ist
die dame auf der linken seite also der
auf der rechten wie marie ist die auf
der linken seite und wir sehen im
unterschiedlich von ihm intro living the
christian lifestyle also den
christlichen lifestyle bekommt diese
nach jetzt wird in den falschen hals
leute es ist mir sehr wichtig vor diesem
video zu betont dass man auf gar keinen
fall diese beiden hätten sollte für ihre
einstellung zum leben die sind eben ja
christliche youtuber auch wenn man das
wort vielleicht in der zusammenstellung
noch nie gehört hat und ja letzten endes
kann jeder selbst bestimmt was er mit
seinem leben machen möchte da haben alle
anderen relativ wenig mitzureden aber
ich bin sehr gespannt was die so zu
sagen haben okay ich hab mir gerade ein
bisschen flashback ich sag mal warum ich
glaube viele von euch wenn er keinen
bezug zu erstellen können und zwar
schaue ich einen amerikanischen youtuber
sehr gern heißt co
[Musik]
der macht auch max mews und hat in einem
video auf seinem kanal auf ja eigentlich
genau das hier geht was ich auch tat
reagiere nur auf englisch also quasi
jedes mal anstelle von zwei
amerikanischen mädels die auch in
christlichen lifestyle auf youtube
beworben haben und da hat er sich ein
bisschen drüber lustig gemacht deswegen
ein kleines déjà vu für mich gerade aber
kreative von dem video ist keins vor der
e3 wie weit darf man gehen und ja also
werden heute schon mal darüber reden was
man aus ihrer meinung in der beziehung
machen darf und was nicht
[Musik]
ja er hier auf der rechten seite ist
vielleicht ein bisschen nervös in diesem
video dabei zu sein ich weiß es nicht
der wirkt ein bisschen bisschen sehr
aufgedreht vielleicht wissen gekünstelt
ich weiß jetzt persönlich nicht wie
viele youtube videos er schon gedreht
hat aber falls er noch am anfang seiner
karriere ist ist es eigentlich
verständlich
ok ja das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
also ich hab so müssen den eindruck die
beiden sind wie so ein rap song zusammen
sie ist so der text zu der mine paten
die lions und er ist so die eclipse ist
was ich meine so die zwischenrufe die
zwischen den zeilen kommen ich sage
immer ein beispiel sie sind sank von den
- so sieht dann so wie coco und er also
und sie sagt no china leverage dann sind
das sind das die deutschen - leute
dieses thema wird ok also man muss sagen
auf jeden fall egal wie man es zieht man
das kritisch sieht oder positiv sieht
ganz neutral gesprochen muss man sagen
dass die position vor der ehe nicht
intim miteinander zu werden also kein
sex zu haben eine extreme position ist
unserer heutigen gesellschaft extrem
deswegen nicht als falsch ist halt
einfach als selten vorkommt aber man
muss sagen das hat auch gesagt die
beiden hier die spielen christentum auf
ultra schwierigkeit es ist schon hart
genug mit allen rückschlägen im leben so
den glauben an gott ich zu verlieren und
so jedes einzelne wort in der bibel
ernst zu nehmen aber die die halten sich
an regel die einfach nicht mal in der
bibel drinstehen normales christentum
das sonst so einfach
wir wollen den nächsten schritt
ja er ist es ganz ehrlich ich persönlich
finde eine frau die anzugeben
das ist eigentlich auch schon sechs
meiner meinung nach menschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
das hat schon mal gesagt heute jeder
kann sein leben leben wie er will und
die zwei sei nicht prinzipiell falsch
weil die eine etwas extremer position
haben aber damit ihr auch ein lustiges
video hat werde ich erstmal so die
punkte herausgreifen die vielleicht ein
bisschen extremer sich darüber lustig
machen ok ok verstanden also angenommen
ist auf meiner freundin so zu hause und
ich hab so hunger und die bringt mir
dann so ein steak was du mein bedürfnis
nach essen befriedigt das ist das dann
ein das ist sex ok also leute jetzt
kommen die grenzen alle zettel raus ist
ja ein bleistift hier ich hab meinen
zettel hier und jetzt jetzt mit
geschrieben heute die grenzen achtung
ich bin bisher unsere erste grenze und
ist eine so wichtige und die empfehle
ich wirklich allen nicht gemeinsam in
einem bett schlafen
ok ja wenn man so praktisch durch denkt
es kann schon kann schon gefährlich
werden also man sollte vielleicht schon
meiner meinung nach bevor man mit
jemanden ehe eingeht mal im bett mit der
person beschlagnahmen weil ich stelle
mir vor du du du heiratest ein mann ist
eure ersten acht hochzeitsnacht ihr
schlaf tibet und der bastard schnarcht
du wusstest einfach nicht wenn du vorher
nie mit dem bett geschlafen hast oder
noch schlimmer links ganz okay ja okay
ist jetzt mein ehemann verein geschissen
okay gut aber wird schon gehen
man schläft seien nach stunden mit
ohropax am nächsten morgen machst du
auch krank warum weil deine bettdecke
geklaut hat so viel zu dem thema nicht
mehr schlafen länger dessen dinge die
man vorher raus finden muss ich weiß
dass viele junge menschen sagen werden
das ist sehr wichtig also nochmal leute
das ist riskant
das ist ich kann euch sagen zwei dinge
auf die man einen partner unbedingt
prüfen muss ist bettdecke klaue rey und
schneiderei wichtig noch macht es das
ungemein schwerer nicht mit jemandem zu
schlafen wenn man zusammen in einem bett
schläft das ist einfach eine
automatische ich glaube dass gar davor
dass ausgewählte wenn die beiden sich
dann doch so in ein bett legen ist
familiär so richtig krass mit sich
selbst zum einfachen anderem deswegen
wir wohnen zwar zusammen in einem haus
also in einem studentenwohnheim und
unsere zimmer sind nah beieinander aber
trotzdem schlafen wir nie zusammen im
selben zimmer de also mal das ist auch
also da ist schon anstrengend ne-yo
jason ganze abend mit deiner freundin
mal davon davon freundin sozusagen davon
sein dass man eine beziehung ist weiß
nicht vielleicht ist es auch verboten
aber sein normales den ganzen abend mit
einer freundin und dann wollt ihr
einfach so schlafen gehen und dann musst
du dich einfach du musst dich dann halt
einfach verpissen du musst gehen weil er
nicht in einem zimmer schlafen dürfe
nicht gedacht dass es so teuer und
anstrengend ist gläubiger christ zu sein
wobei das wahrscheinlich nur auf
ultimativer schwierigkeit
hallo was habe ich da gerade gehört ob
das endgültige aus rhede ist ja der
andere hat die ganze nacht gekommen
ja und jetzt willst jetzt in fahrt komme
spiele oder nicht nur zwei ist natürlich
auch dass man sich nicht nackt sieht das
heißt man sich schon bald geht geht man
nicht in eine umkleidekabine oder wenn
er sich umziehen will einmal jetzt
gleich weg gehen dann gehe ich natürlich
aus so war aus ok hat man das wirklich
so wenig unter kontrolle
sie werden bald in einer umkleide jetzt
stehst du da auf einmal silizium
also ja leute was sagen sie zu diesem
video ich glaube die wichtigste
zusammenfassung ist so benutzt euren
kopf benutzt seinen kopf ja nicht jeder
der an den christlichen gott glaubt ist
so extrem darauf wie die und nur weil
ich so eine extreme position haben sind
nicht per se schlechte menschen oder so
man sollte erst recht nicht hätten dass
man ganz wichtig leute hated die nicht
auch wenn die bisschen lustiger extreme
sachen erzählt ist nicht irgendein grund
dazu hätten finde ich das war so was von
mir leute ich hab ich hier drüben ein
wahrscheinlich eine sünde darstellen das
video verlinkt bis zum nächsten mal
leute bleibt stabil bleibt enthaltsam
macht's gut